[Music]
here we are
we did it finally
[Music]
i'm so embarrassed that we're doing
a podcast about wellness and you're sick
as a dog
[Laughter]
i'm so embarrassed like you feel you
failed
yes i failed you i feel like i'm
embarrassing you
i don't take responsibility for what you
do
because you have sort of
helped me um live my life
to the fullest oh good into the like
optimal life force
and now i'm meeting you and you're sick
as a dog
i'm on death's door no we all get sick
we all get sinus infections
this is so dumb being sick is so dumb
yeah but it's not it's so embarrassing i
don't think so
i don't think it's like a you have to
measure you have to like
i have to keep myself from getting sick
to make myself
proclaim i'm healthy yeah as soon as i
feel that i'm getting sick i go into a
deep denial
and i start like working and organizing
i get like manic
actually to try to outrun it outrun the
sickness
how does that work
i'll show those germs right i'll show
them
that's a good approach but isn't some of
being sick psychological
i'm sure i'm sure yeah but it's also
very physical and biochemical and if you
have a sinus infection
you probably need antibiotics and that's
all good
i have a full blown z
sinus infection yeah uh i'm living in my
house through construction
uh i didn't know this was a
a danger a danger no i didn't know air
was dangerous
but i think like we were texting like
getting sick every now and then is good
for your immune system
it's a challenge no obviously if you're
sick every month that's a problem
yeah so if you're if you're challenging
your immune system and this is
part of the problem if you look at kids
right we don't challenge them anymore
they live in these very sterile
environments vaccinate the hell out of
them don't let them play outside
right and then their their immune system
is very
turned off from anything outside of
themselves and then they're eight years
old and they get their first
exposure to germs and their immune
system flips out and then they have this
autoimmune disease and
i mean that's the extreme your kids
should be playing in the sandbox and
eating dirt
literally yeah exposing themselves yeah
right to the elements that's all healthy
and
what is um did were kids always allergic
to peanuts
it's such a good question right this is
a new thing
it seemed very very new yeah i think
part of it is because if you take an
immune system which hasn't been exposed
to anything
and for whatever reason on a peanut
shellfish
now it gets overwhelmed by the smallest
exposure of something benign
it's very again but it comes from that
keeping kids in a very sterile
environment
being afraid for them to be in outdoors
and the elements exposed to other kids
like that's a massive problem for people
this proves my point that
bad parents are the best parents there's
some truth to that yeah
like go outside and play and we'll just
go outside and play
come back when it gets dark right that's
what my mom used to say
for sure you know don't wash your hands
i mean we're in a pandemic now please
don't cancel me for that but like you
know you gotta get dirty as a kid gotta
live
yeah gotta get outside get out of the
house
kids don't do that anymore do we get
more allergies
if we weren't exposed to something early
in life i think so so if you look at how
does that happen it's i mean
a very like big view of this is
allergies
is in a sense the immune system saying
we're scared
right like we're scared we don't know
what this is yeah it's foreign
right like we have to flip out because
we we're afraid of it whereas pollen
and trees and grass are not scary things
but when you train your immune system
that it has to be so in line and so
sterile
well of course if then you're exposed to
something that's never been exposed to
it can flip out
let me backtrack for a second yeah do
you want to introduce yourself
sure what do you do for a living dr
conover i
i talk to people help them optimize
their life we have doctors on the show
yeah so i call it performance medicine
like because i help people
not just feel well but perform their
best which is very different than like
functional medicine alternative medicine
which i think is
robotic just helping people kind of they
end up doing a lot of lab testing and
putting people in tons of supplements
yeah which is just like the
pharmaceutical model except we've
replaced
pharmaceuticals with nutrients and say
it's all safe and really good but then
people end up on 28 different
supplements not knowing what they're
doing
nothing and nothing gets changed and
it's kind of the mindset of taking this
for that
i think is a problem i think that
the stress of taking
the random supplements i have is worse
for me
than not oh i totally doing anything
right
no it struck me
it's like i'm so stressed out about what
vitamins i should and shouldn't take
that the cortisol released from that is
probably worse i'm sure oh i agree with
that
like if you don't if you don't have a
game plan to it then what are you doing
what are you doing
and and you can always add another right
because now you're you tweaked your
elbow so you need to take
the glucosamine for the pain but now
you're on 16 others because why not it's
natural
right it's safe what's what should
everyone be on
there's some staples yeah like like fish
oil
fish oil and i say this odd liver oil
cod liver is not fish oil
i mean cuddle rolls comes from fish you
know but it's not traditional fish oil
which comes from things like anchovies
mackerel sardines okay
but i say this because we do a lot of
testing with our patients like
fatty acids are always low vitamin d is
always low
b vitamins tend to be low um then then
other fat soluble vitamins like vitamin
a
vitamin k2 coq10 those are big things
some would argue probiotics you're
you're taking those every morning
some i'm not personally but yeah yeah i
mean people
probably should if they're looking to
cover in an efficient way there's like
four things vitamin d fatty acids
probiotics would be the top of the list
but we can get vitamin d from the sun
right you can't really i mean
some people can but you you get it but
you can't convert inactive vitamin d
we wear sunscreen all the time well i
don't think it's just sunscreen i think
from the skin can't convert inactive
vitamin d to active vitamin d
that's the issue so we measure people's
levels and it should be
literally the range is 30 to 100 should
be greater than 70 and that's based on
studies that show when you're greater
than 70 you don't get cancer things like
that
right don't break your bones those are
important things yeah
but most people can't get there
certainly can't get there if they don't
take
supplements someone listening right now
that's not getting drafted for the nfl
it's not an mma that's not joe rogan
yeah like what's going to the gnc
the local grocery store like what do you
get
i'd get vitamin d you take butter every
day vitamin d3
d3 what's the three what what's there
one chemical
no there is vitamin d2 yeah who names
these things
that's a good question i certainly i
certainly don't know
but but vitamin d3 take five to ten
thousand international units a day
take it with food get fish oil and what
does it do
vitamin d i'm gonna ask some really dumb
questions no it's not dumb it's good
it's uh does a lot of things helps the
immune system kind of keeps the immune
system kind of consistently running
helps a lot with hormones it helps
obviously with bone structure
um but i think most of it's the immune
system d3 is a
no-brainer that's easy gotta do it yeah
got it yeah what else fish oil or flax
seed oil
fish or flax seed or krill oil depending
on how you want real oil
because why am i hearing that some fish
oils have mercury in them is this
because
no no no i mean if you look at just like
people eating lots of fish so they say
if you eat if you want to do it the best
way the ideal way
is eat fish from different water sources
like
rotate it bury it up because if you're
eating the same fish from the same water
source
you're going to tend to collect what's
in that same water source which in a lot
of water sources are mercury
so because water sources have mercury in
them because of the
um well lots of things there's a lot of
so much pollution
and then so our fish are full of mercury
now some i mean
there's a good website it's like
remember like dot milk it's you can go
it's like got mercury.org
oh really yeah got mercury.org and you
can look at the different mercury
content of the most
common fish that people eat like
swordfish i think's the highest yeah
right
don't eat swordfish right don't eat
swordfish right tuna is not great
yeah but like salmon's great like so it
depends on so eat different fish from
different food
water sources to avoid the
you know constant mercury d3 salmon oil
or fish oil oil there is salmon oil
that's specific but most fish oil if you
look at it's from mackerel
anchovies have you seen them sardines
those things that uh
uh some grocery stores have that's like
a it's like fish oil but it's like
fruity it's like a
like a drink it's like a candy yeah yeah
well i mean that's like the whole
vitamin gummy things i want my fish oil
to taste like skittles
right well everyone does it's like a
drinkable fish oil
so i think with a lot of these
supplements they're just trying to be
creative with how do people get it
and i think the trouble is they put a
lot of artificial stuff and sugar
it's probably counteracting oh shit
right
shit yeah we like we do like the
flintstones
i love gotta use this linster i was like
these are vitamins
right it's halloween these are my
candies right so there's something for
that yeah yeah
okay d3 fish oil or flaxseed oil if you
don't want like fish
if you don't want a fish sauce yeah
because i feel like i'm burping up
yeah so one trick with that just put
them in the freezer and they'll just be
more slowly digested you won't burp it
up
yeah yeah we do the ritual vitamins
they're like um
then they have a little mint tab in them
so you're not like burping up yeah
so vitamin d so fatty acids would be
fish or flaxseed or krill oil
and probably the best is to rotate them
you know like every three months or so
switch
so you don't over expose yourself to the
same stuff every three months
switch your fish yeah whoa
yeah just to keep it simple because we
don't want to over expose ourselves
that's why i like people even with
vitamins don't take them every day take
the weekends off
give yourself a break which helps people
anyway because people as we're talking
about get sick of taking the same stuff
all the time
so if we put breaks in there people are
like okay i can handle that but more
importantly
they're then toning down what they
expose themselves to all the time
yeah i mean i've i forget to take them
so
is there some natural attrition or
people go on vacation or go just don't
take them
so then you build a break into it so and
what does the break do
well just i mean my thought is anything
you expose yourself to consistently over
time you render it less potent
anything yeah so your body gets used
we're super adopters and females you're
super super adopters
so you uh adapt very quickly to your in
you know immediate environment
so if you're always taking the same
stuff always eating the same foods
always thinking the same thoughts
always working out the same i know
always working the same way
yeah you're you're not going to make
progress so
super adapters humans we're the only
species that can live anywhere on the
planet
i literally i remember um
i was doing a stand-up
outside for cars right we were all doing
stand-up inside for
human beings and and then it was like
we're doing standing for cars is so
weird everyone's in their car and
they're honking instead of laughing and
there's a nightmare
the weirdest part of it is that five
minutes in
felt totally normal that's how fast
it felt fine yeah you acclimate
acclimate we acclimate
what we're able to normalize
the news that what we see i mean
everything yeah
it's like uh baby murdered i'm like next
scroll yeah doesn't matter what i have
been able to just like neutralize so
quickly
it really scares me yeah but if you take
it back then to things like food and
people are in the same foods every day
they're walking or running on the
treadmill for 30 minutes every day like
that's not doing them any good
taking the same supplements every day
same thought patterns every day
you don't go anywhere you don't
challenge yourself the idea is to be
dynamic and 100 change challenge
challenge surprise consistent
inconsistencies
whoa because i feel like
i feel like so much of mental and
physical wellness has been about like
routine and
consistency and do it every day i think
i think that's a practice to get into
then you get to that place where you're
even keel and you're there and then you
got to change it up again wow
because then you'll just adjust you'll
make that's your new baseline
right and you don't know how high you
could really go right right
like you've reached here the plateau and
then you're like well what about up here
well the only way to get there is to
challenge and it sometimes
many times it's uncomfortable and it's
but that's the growth
what's the biggest mistake everyone's
making oh that's a good question
i know there were probably a lot like
like uh
soy milk's healthy so soy is not healthy
so
i don't think that's the biggest mistake
but soy is not healthy but why
like i guess i think so here's what i
think if i one thing i think is that
people place
way too much emphasis on different types
of diets
and they say like oh i'm going to be
paleo keto
south beach vegetarian
vegan carnivore right and i think the
reality is is what you think about the
food matters more than what the food is
yeah and there was a study i tell this a
lot there's a study i'll mess up the
details which prove that
they took a group of thai women and a
group of swedish women right
first part of study they had the same
nutritional content the food gave the
thai women traditional thai food the
swedish women traditional swedish food
ate the food then after they drew their
blood and looked at certain nutritional
markers
second part of the study they flipped it
so the swedish women eat thai food
thai women eat swedish food same thing
drew their blood third part of study
they pureed the food so it didn't even
look like food anymore
all three parts of study had different
nutritional content from the blood
it's the exact same food the highest was
when traditional the first part when
the thai women ate traditional thai food
and the swedish women ate traditional
sweet food and the thought is
what you know they're more comfortable
and familiar with that so they get more
out of it
literally so what you think about your
food is way more important than what the
food is so
i tell people i'd rather you love
mcdonald's than hate the kale salad
right this is like blowing my mind
yeah but it's true like what and that
applies to everything in your life
like we were talking before about the
placebo effect and like what you think
about it is really going to matter
help the outcome and the inverse is true
as well
don't hate fuck your food no because
also i remember um
i was trying so hard i think everyone's
trying so hard to be healthy
and the amount of stress that you
release
trying to be healthy um i remember i was
like
in an airport um touring and it was like
sorrow pizza taco about you know your
choices and i was like
none of this is healthy and it was like
i remember talking to this um kind of
amazing uh
uh woman that was uh helping me with
like
which was my first like step to meeting
you and she was like
the stressing out over eating the thing
is so much worse
than just eating just have the piece of
pizza yeah
yeah there's a good book by a
sociologist from stanford called um
why zebras don't get ulcers yes yes
there's a lot of people reading them
kind of one of the points is that
animals in the wild don't think about
the food they're eating yeah they don't
have guilt
they're eating whatever they want they
move on to the next thing like we're the
only people have guilt over
everything we eat like we beat ourselves
up like i'm a bad person because i had
that cookie
we are we are at war with what we eat
it's like i just
i'm going to eat this piece of cake i'm
going to work out for two hours tomorrow
it's like fucking just fucking cause i
hate myself what is this cheat day
thing well i think a cheat day if you're
on a very restrictive diet
or extreme diet is necessary it's a
safety valve yeah
because if you don't i think what
happens is if you're like keto it can be
if you're really restrictive keto that's
going to be a challenge for you to
maintain all the time
because you want carbohydrates you want
pizza like we all do
and so if you don't give yourself the tj
you're going to be thinking about that
all the time i think
right so if you give yourself a cheat
day it's like okay it's a safety valve
i can have some pizza and it's fine it's
part of my plan uh-huh
yeah but it also going back at
that changing it up i think is good but
i
i don't i i've as you know i have a
history with like eating disorders that
i have such a
you know acrimonious relationship with
food and in in my past like
i don't want to not eat thing like i
don't want to have an adversarial
adversarial relationship with food like
bread can i bread
if you want it thank you why
why is bread like i'm not giving it
bread i don't i truly know
i agree that's why this whole push and
like that all these
carbs are bad no they're not i mean yeah
they're just not we think they're bad
but the way it's made in america and
sure and the versus the way it's made
there's there's more reaction yeah
that goes back to probably some of what
we talked about initially with how we're
raising kids and keeping things sterile
and
yeah it's all tied in but what you think
about whatever you're doing is certainly
going to tie in more it's going to be
the most immediate thing
so if you come at it like i shouldn't
have bread i'm a bad person
of course the bread's not gonna be good
for you how could it be why would you
want to eat it that way
so so much of your work is about the
emotion
like the neuro chemicals that are
released around
the mindset of it the mindset practicing
of the mindset of abundance
yeah explain that well most people you
know it's fear-based
right like we're just fearful creatures
like everything we do we have to make
sure it's okay
as opposed to being comforted like
everything i do is always going to be
good
so i think when i see people one of the
first questions i'm trying to understand
is do they
do they and their lens of the world feel
like the world is safe or not safe
most people feel like it's unsafe yes
yeah absolutely so the decisions that
they make whether it's what they're
going to work out what they're going to
wear
thoughts they think food come back to
that question
so what then they're playing defense
then what well you got to undo that you
got to give them some things to show
them that like it's okay to try
ketamine right yeah nad yeah peptides
whatever it is
that you may be uncomfortable get out of
your comfort zone oh my goodness you
felt
you know 30 you know it's 30 percent
better
and like okay i can feel better okay i
can start to trust this a little bit
more
okay so let's talk about it yeah so
you uh do a ketamine oxytocin spray
nasal spray nasal spray
yes which i cannot use right now because
of my sinus infection
right so we started doing um we do a lot
of intravenous nad
um for years can you explain what nad is
everyone's heard about it on rogan i
know but yeah so
so nad is a b3 vitamin derivative it's a
chemical cousin of niacin
the vitamin um been in use since really
the 1930s where they found it was
helpful for addiction actually
and and actually it turns off cravings
better than probably any substance
turns off cravings yeah so they called
it the predator syndrome when people
whether it's alcohol or opiates so they
can't get their stuff to become a
predator
they need it yep and they found that nad
turned that off
like this so it's been really helpful in
addiction treatment that's where it kind
of grew up
ignored by mainstream medicine
conventional medicine
resurfaced in the 90s where they're
doing intravenous nad
for addiction and people came from all
over in 2005 a gentleman from the states
had a pain medicine addiction
traveled to mexico got the protocol
changed his life
at that time there's only one injectable
nad from south africa he
purchased the distribution rights which
he still owns and then opened a clinic
in atlanta
called executcare where all they did was
addiction work well i've been doing
intravenous nutrients for a long time
longer than most and
got to know him would refer him patients
and at some point i don't remember when
he came to me and said he needed help
with nad
because more and more people were doing
it they just don't know how to do it he
wasn't a doctor he needed someone to
help so we
took it on and kind of reshaped doing a
lot of testing with it and
so we've overseen more nad driven than
probably anywhere else in the world like
we do a lot of nad what does it do to
your cells
so i think it's like cellular fitness
yeah like literally so the mitochondria
people are familiar with let's be dorks
yeah so these whole doors yeah these are
the batteries
of the cells okay and so because they're
the batteries and by the way there's not
just one per cell there's
potentially thousands per every cell we
have these batteries
that in the very simplistic form take
the fuel that you eat
carbs protein fat and turn it into atp
energy
atp like i remember that from high
school adenosine treatment i wasn't
listening
yeah i should have listed but anything
anything you want to do in your life
you need energy yes think a thought move
a finger eat you
because i just i mean
you guys know me like i'm such a
workaholic like i was
i just have been tired for
so long like deliri like
before i started working with you i was
like deliriously tired for
so long but also couldn't sleep and i
was in like a manic
state of like not being able to sleep
but always being exhausted and i just
felt like i
was wasting my life like i just wasn't
optimal yeah
you know and i just felt like i was in
this like haze and i would go to doctors
they would say i'd have
adrenal fatigue they say i had um
you know is is this depression is that
like is it being a woman
and is it my moods am i pmsing like
there's just so much it's so
overwhelming
like and i run myself really hard
and or my quality of sleep is not good
enough so it's like it's hard to just
like
sort of separate and delineate every
sort of thing
it is i don't think but i think that's
almost too much pressure because i think
for all of us we have different dials
that we work on
right it's not always going to be
consistent we're never going to get it
perfect right
it's a work in progress yeah i mean
there's some few key things i i would
say nad is one of those key things it's
foundational so how can
people access nad like yeah so most
people are not going to be able to do
ivs
yeah it's not accessible it can be too
expensive because there's a cost
associated people aren't going to choose
that
but that's the gold standard like that's
what we find is you really want to you
think in the future that this will be
like a part of like
it'll be covered by health insurance and
we'll be like never
no i don't think so it won't be like
advil at some point
i don't think so i think in part because
um you know there's that tying with the
pharmaceutical companies and the
insurance companies and that whole
paradigm of conventional medicine they
don't want us to get better
there's not a wellness component right
yeah i remember years ago
we used to do a lot more primary care
and i remember you
and you had to submit these codes for
insurance and they wouldn't pay
to talk to someone about smoking
cessation right they wouldn't pay you 45
but then i had a patient had open heart
surgery and that was three hundred
thousand dollars
and they'd be happy to pay that so
how does that work it's really dark yeah
so
i don't think so but i think so but
that's a common question is like well
then most people can't afford it
i i think most people can i think it's a
it's a series of choices you make in
your life right if you place value
on really wellness and optimizing your
health then you will understand that
it's time energy and money yeah and
that's hard and that's
people don't want to admit it and we're
materialistic society so we'll go and
spend a lot of money on our shoes
yes yes but we would never do that for
ourselves and that's the big question
why not
but it's is it available in pill for
like
so people there's these uh nad
precursors
different brands yeah um where they're
using different molecules one's nr
one's nmn i think they're okay yeah
i mean that's you know but i don't think
they're what we see with
intravenous nad or we'll use it
subcutaneous just like peptide shots
yes one of the peptides everyone's
asking everyone wants to know
um you can do it sublingual what
sublingual under the tongue
so there's different ways to get nad
into one system we made these lollipops
these lollipops that are on my desk yeah
gum we're making
it the only reason i'm alive you guys
it's just fyi yes is my
dr frankenstein so
we're big proponents of using the source
which is nad
to raise your energy levels and then
there's just so much research
from the the sickness side like
cancer heart disease neurodegenerative
going back to those mitochondria being
faulty
as we live and stress out our bodies and
kind of repairing those
and then on the wellness side anti-aging
anti-diabetes all goes back to that same
mitochondria
so they're a big deal yeah and so nad is
a huge deal because that's foundation of
how you get those mitochondria working
their best
literally i know it's the new year and i
know that means that everyone's trying
to do their best to eat better to be
better that's how you start new years we
just want to eat better at the beginning
of all the new years
and that sounds good in theory but you
know what you really want to do is you
want to wake up
and eat a lovely bowl of multi-colored
shapes and with magic spoon
you can do that without having to worry
about any of the bad stuff
that's usually in cereal magic spoon has
zero sugar
12 grams of protein only three net carbs
in each serving they have a variety of
flavors they actually offer a custom
variety box
so that you can try the flavors you want
to try they have
cocoa they have fruity they have frosted
they have blueberry and there's plus
there's
two new flavors peanut butter and
cinnamon which sound lovely mixed
together
they're keto gluten-free grain-free
soy-free low-carb and gmo
free and they taste amazing go to
magicspoon.com
whitney to get a variety pack and try it
today
oh have you guys haven't tried this yet
what are you doing are you insane
be sure to use our promo code whitney at
checkout to save five dollars on your
order
the these are so delicious i eat
literally i go through two boxes a week
magic spoon is so confident in its
product it's back with 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason send it to me
but they'll also refund your money no
questions asked that's magicspoon.com
whitney use the code whitney to save
five dollars oof
uh thank you magic spoon for sponsoring
the podcast
well we made it through 2020 and now
we're in 2021 and that does not mean
that we're gonna stop working on
ourselves
which is why we're still here working
with better help
better help can help you i'm pretty sure
it's in the title
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with a licensed professional
therapist you can start communicating in
under 48 hours
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it's professional counseling
done securely online
and their services are available
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime
and message your counselor that is
pretty impressive i can think of anyone
i can message and they would message me
back in 48 hours that's
this is great better help wants you to
start living a happier life today
i'm going to redo this is great because
didn't it sound rude i'm going to say
this is great that sounds about it right
better help want you to start living a
happier life today
visit betterhelp.com whitney that's
better h-e-l-p
join the over 1 million people taking
charge of their
ex mental health which i have a lot of
with the help of an experienced
professional now you guys might know
what benton does this
the fact that so many people have been
using better help
i swear i'm a little high but this is
ridiculous
that there are recruiting they're
recruiting additional counselors in all
50 states so now you have some hot
gossip about the company
special offers for good for you
listeners get 10 off your first month
betterhelp.com whitney
are peptides why i look so good i think
100.
everyone thinks i got like a facelift
yeah
peptides are really neat what what is
what are they so peptides i i keep
recommending them to people knowing
like i don't know what they are so
peptides you know i think i'm a doctor
right
i get that i know way more about all
this to do i'm just letting you
yeah pontification yeah yeah yeah no
please continue
so peptides are chains of amino acids
chains what's an amino acid amino acid
what we think of as like the building
blocks of life
so things like
so they go into things making bones and
ligaments tendons and neurotransmitters
kind of solid structures they're
important to shit
they're very important and so what a
peptide is is you're taking those amino
acids so all natural putting them into
novel combinations to do certain things
we want them to do in that okay
so they kind of grew up in the crossfit
community the competitive crossfitters
are looking for an edge
and they're kind of like modern day
anabolic steroids because they work
really well
but they're better than the steroids
because they don't really cause the side
effects
and that was one group there's growth
hormone releasing peptides
so people may familiar with be familiar
with things like eye primordial and
samurai and dhrp6 ghrp
brain is just yeah a lot of eyes glazing
over yeah
well who names these things yeah that's
a good question i'm like obsessed with
like the meeting where they're like
isapralin i submit drexatrin
that that's how gravely rolls off the
tongue yeah
like who like it's a great question the
naming is so
rude it's it makes it hard to embrace
it's really just it's such a fuck you
like doctors are
such i don't think doc well who is it or
pharmaceutical people
yeah some of these psycho by lexa tram
like why
that yeah why it's probably something
with google like
why do you hate dyslexic people so much
no that's a great question yeah i don't
have that answer
it's just it's to make us feel stupid
probably
when they're like do you still have your
meds what are you what are you on dexter
try labma
fenilow yeah with a y in the middle
right for no reason yeah x there's an x
next to a z
right right things in what world
in their world and you know i'm i'm it's
a painkiller you know i'm high i can't
read anyway
i already can't read it normal words
yeah sorry good point you digress my
rant yeah
i there's a really pisses me off
okay i don't have a good answer
i really can't comment i really want to
do i'm really where what
it's cause i have so many dogs in on
meds yeah and they're all just like
weird trasomatophila milk boof
yeah like flying
um i digress yeah
peptides so the chains of amino acids
put into an
uh injectable form people inject them
subcutaneously under the skin really
small needle and then do certain things
so there's peptides for fitness peptides
for the nervous system peptides for the
immune system
peptides for skin and they all kind of
work together to
lead to amazing skin so dope
yeah very very safe that's the best part
about peptides
because a lot of people are taking hgh
for a while that's no good because it
makes your i'm a doctor
uh it makes your pituitary glands stop
producing testosterone on its own
okay right not really
damn it webmd you failed me again but
people overdo growth hormone we still
use growth hormone i think it has its
place yeah yeah for people with an acute
injury there's nothing like growth
hormone
is cortisone shots are those bad uh it
depends i don't think anything's
always bad yeah yeah i mean if you've
got some influence if you've got
terrible poison ivy
yeah like that'll be a godsend yeah
because i was doing cortisone shots in
cystic
zits for a while oh yeah and it like
it's not good for your skin
well then you can get depressions and
then yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean
everything is a trade-off
yeah so it's just how bad you need it
right versus what it's going to do for
you
right yeah so i don't i think there's a
time and place for cortisone shots
so what are the other like major
mistakes we're making every day
the way we're sleeping the quality of
sleep yeah i think sleep's a big deal i
think
i think the challenge with sleep is that
people don't realize like this taps into
the hormone cortisol which is not
cortisone but it's the natural one
within us that our adrenal glands make
when they said you had adrenal fatigue
they're saying you're not keeping up
with how you produce cortisol
or how you respond to stress and i think
that's a really big deal
i don't think people understand cortisol
is like the sun rises in the morning
sets in the evening
and when you put the kids down or you're
you know quiet for a little bit at night
and then all of a sudden you're
watching tv or on your phone for two
hours or you at 10 o'clock want to go
work out
you're asking your body to put out a lot
more cortisol
it's not supposed to do it then so we're
changing that
and so now you have more cortisol in
your world than you should and that
blunts then the release of growth
hormone testosterone melatonin
so you can't recover at night so i think
cortisol is a daytime thing
just be catabolic during the day
anabolic antibiotics healing mending
repair rejuvenation
so starting at 8 pm no working out
well we go out we go to dinner we go to
parties i know so
we should be dorks well i think we're
designed to we're really designed to go
to bed when the sun goes down 100
but this is why i think people adapt
we're super deaf so we adapt to this new
norm and i think it's fine for the first
couple decades of life
so people in their 20s and 30s kind of
hang out and do fine yeah when people
hit
40s 50s things start to fall apart yeah
i'd argue that's because we've lost
this that disconnect with cortisol
that's that big of a deal
we can't do it anymore and so we start
feeling badly but
should you when you're in your 20s cha
like
go out at five and come home at 10.
i mean i think if you're living by the
rhythm of cortisol yes
yeah and part of it's the problem living
in a normal digital
technology-based world i'm not going to
say
don't use your phone at 10 o'clock at
night like that's stupid yeah or don't
go out to eat or don't go out
no one's going to do that but if you can
have that general premise
i think it's very helpful yeah
but that's part of the problem and we've
we're disconnected from the natural
elements
going back to where we talked about kids
or sitting in their home playing video
games yeah
that's the new norm grounding is that
anything
placebo effect i think it's more of you
know you can never isolate and say oh
it's because you put your bare feet on
the ground but you're also outside
yeah you're breathing in air you've made
the choice that it's healthy to be
outside yeah
that there's a lot that goes into that
versus oh you put your feet on the
ground
i dated an anesthesiologist once
uh because i make good choices and he
told me
uh is this true or false that um part of
why
smoking is so relaxing is you're taking
like deep inhales
it could be standing outside i mean i
think also it's like
if you take a smoke break it's like
you're allowed to have a five minute
break
yeah right yeah but if you just said i
need a break people are like why do you
need a break
yeah like keep working but it's okay to
take five minutes to smoke what is this
standing desk yoga ball
sitting on a bike do we need to be
standing at our desks are we sitting too
much
probably sitting too much that would
make sense yeah i think it's gonna be
real if you just think about like
just a good way to think about what did
people used to do when you didn't have
all this technology yeah
most of what they did for exercise was
walking like 95
of it walking's a great exercise every
now and then they had to run really fast
yeah every now and then they had to lift
something heavy yeah they eat a variety
of diet
based on the seasons based what was
available like the bed with the sun i
mean those are all good things to live
by
and then you kind of filter those things
into your world it's always going to be
better than
all this technology but it's like it's
like to me it's like when i
go to these offices now and everyone's
standing on their standing desk
i yeah it's weird yeah
it's not like a game changer no
but it goes back to if you really
thought that that's a game changer for
you then maybe so but i'd say most
people don't
the reason they're doing is because joe
schmoe next to them is doing and they
feel like i got to keep up with him
yeah we're all just trying to fit in
yeah they're not owning that decision
like
oh i really want to stand because it's
good for me another thing like everyone
else is doing it i might as well
that's the problem that's like a very
old like tribal instinct of like to fit
in
with the tribe and i think that's
probably bad
right if you're doing what the herd is
doing yeah you're probably not going to
have the most success in life because i
mean
you can sit and work at your computer
just get up
and go for a walk every couple hours
yeah whatever feels right and in terms
of exercise and the surprising your body
thing like that's
that's such a so mind-blowing to me
because i went to
a chiropractor a couple years ago and i
was doing soul spinning class
spinning class and he was like he made a
joke looking back sort of inappropriate
he was like um yeah he's like yeah i'm
gonna buy my vacation
house off of uh soul cycle injuries
because he was just like your body's not
meant to do the same thing over and over
and over
yeah i mean i have a number of um very
you know even professional level cyclist
patients and they'll be the first to
tell you that they're screwed up
mechanically
oh it's hard for them so if you're uh
committed to working out and you don't
do the same thing every time
correct i think that's a really good
rule of thumb
because well there's all this because
you adapt to it so if you're
the easiest example is walking on the
treadmill right yeah because people used
to do that forever they'd run on the
treadmill for 30 minutes and say
great i'm healthy i exercise you're not
though because you're not really
challenging yourself right you're
challenging yourself at first
you're going but then you're gonna be at
that plateau yeah how does that
challenge your
mindset of it how's it challenged it
doesn't challenge anything you're using
the same muscle it should never be easy
is that fair to say yeah i think that's
probably fair it shouldn't be easy
yeah is crossfit good i mean i think
crossfit's okay the trouble across is
they do these different lifts and moves
which
um there's a lot of back injuries it's a
little psychotic yeah a lot of back
injuries and they tend to be very
gung-ho very competitive and so then
they push themselves to compete
injure themselves and i don't know
we're in 2021 and we are still talking
about manscaped okay just because you
made it through 2020 doesn't mean that
your pubic region
can be an apocalyptic wasteland okay you
still got to take care of it
there'll be no there'll be no slacking
in 2021 on that either
which is why we're still working with
manscaped who is the best in men's below
the waste grooming
manscape is taking over the world and is
now available in all of europe canada uk
and australia the world
is going to be a lot less hairy
yeah it is manscaped offers the
lawnmower 3.0 which is an electric
trimmer that you've been missing that
you
you have been missing out on this
because it is truly
the best trimmer you could have you
could have you could have pubic hair
like
barbed wire and it would cut through it
glide right through it there's a light
it's waterproof
fantastic and you can get one for 20
off 20 off and free shipping at
manscape.com
whitney and i can't talk about manscape
without mentioning whitney's
favorite product from them the weed
whacker which is their nose and ear hair
trimmer
i mean she that the weed whacker is
literally
on the podcast table at all times
whether we're doing a manscaped ad or
not she has on the table and she's
showing it to people
she's talking about it she's using it
she loves it
i mean it's a great product so whether
you're into the lawnmower 3.0 or the
weed whacker person i think you should
get them both
manscaped has something for you get 20
off in free shipping at manscape.com
whitney
that's 20 off with free shipping and
easy shaving at manscape.com whitney
your balls will thank you and so will
the random girls you meet on
hinge honestly doordash should be my
nickname and i'm sprinting to the door
to get the food they're dropping off i
love doordash
love it okay you can have you just open
the app you can pick from any
food you're craving and they will bring
it right to you drop it off at your door
with their new contactless delivery
drop-off setting
and then you have the meal of your
dreams pretty much there's over 300 000
partners for doordash in the u.s puerto
rico canada and australia
and you can support local go-to's or you
can choose a national
favorites restaurant like wendy's or the
cheesecake factory
big fan right now our listeners can get
five dollars off and zero delivery fees
on their
first order of 15 or more when you
download the door
dash app and how have you guys not
downloaded this it's like such a game
changer
and enter code good for you that's five
dollars off and zero delivery fees on
your first order
when you download the door dash app and
the app store and enter good for you
it's the only reason i have survived
don't forget that's code good for you
for five dollars off your first order
with the door dash
i want to go back to the other vitamin
vitamin d fish oil
some kind of krill oil or or flax seed
oil
right what's the other have to have it
every day
i mean i would say probiotics is a big
choice okay but probiotics that
i'm i'm hearing some of them don't
absorb and in the pill form and you have
they have to be live and they have to be
refrigerated which one so there's some
caveats
yep so they're live cells so you need
them refrigerated so it has to be when
you go to the grocery store
the ones that are in the fridge that are
like look like yogurty
correct pills are like no you can take
pills but they yeah you can take pills
literally they'll be like a 1 billion
probiotics
so a good starting level is 25 billion
okay that's about
minimal and it's going to keep in there
it does
you can they can make some like um very
thin capsule
things that dissolve that's not okay the
pills are not a scab
no i think powder is batter powdered
probiotics okay
that goes in like a drink you can go and
drink put in water put in yogurt or
something eat it
so expiration date on the bottle they're
live cells yes
refrigerated every day and then or
monday through friday or something
all right 25 billion starts and they're
they're graded in terms of colony
forming units not milligrams
so cfus yeah and then don't take them
too much too quickly or get bloating
you know mess up your stomach digestion
because what it does is it
it repopulates your gut with healthy
bacteria because
why is there not enough healthy bacteria
in our guts well
what people don't realize too is
actually there's more foreign dna in our
bodies than human dna did you know that
yeah pretty strong cray yeah does that
mean our ancestors were raped
no it means the bacteria in our gut
there's more of that and than
and then they're literally human dna so
the question becomes who's colonizing
you
it's so gross yeah it's weird to think
about but we also have bugs in our
eyelashes right
yeah maybe some of us we also have mites
in our eyebrows okay yeah let's just
skip the groceries
so so but it goes back to probiotics
because we're to have to take
these live cultures healthy bacteria
because
we are exposed to things that stress our
guts out
right like eating the wrong foods taking
antibiotics taking steroids it wears
down the gut line
yeah changes the gut microbiota right
yeah
and so we have imbalance and then we
have imbalance because 80
of the immune system lives in the gut
and it's a whole cascading of events
got it yeah just take probiotics well
take them with those caveats
yeah yeah jesus it's a great thing okay
probiotics are a yes yes vitamin d3
um fatty acids oil i would put in coq10
because i think it's such a
cocuta coenzyme what is it it's a fat
soluble antioxidant maybe the most
powerful antioxidant fights free
radicals there you go dude is that right
yeah
dr whitney yeah square one for doctor
you can leave now
um okay so why why i didn't know why
i'm like i just feel like people are
taking so much shit
like the state and everyone's taking it
i got to take this i like i
understand why here's the simplistic why
we are water soluble organisms okay
living in a fat-soluble world
okay yes so it's the job of our liver to
take the stuff we're exposed to
like let's keep it really simple
pesticides herbicides toxicities in the
environment
right and change them from this fat
soluble thing to a water soluble thing
so we can excrete it or get rid of it
right when we do that it's two phases of
liver detoxification we've heard phase
one phase two
when we do that we actually phase one
makes it worse for us that's where you
produce that free radical
right and then phase two go back to
those amino acids you add the amino
acids
things like glutathione methionine
different amino acids
that then the analogy i use is phase one
is you take the trash put in the trash
bag
put it on the side of the road right
phase two the trash trucks come to pick
it up right
unfortunately we are way behind most
people we have way too much trash on the
side of roads we don't have enough trash
trucks
so that's that's a free radical sitting
there oh interesting and there's very
few things in nature that
make us have more trash trucks
independent of making more trash on the
side of the road
so things like this is why you're eating
colorful fruits and vegetables
the oranges the yellows the reds the
purples help phase two
matcha green tea helps us make more
trash trucks
and so then we can excrete the bad stuff
kombucha
kombucha is fermented yes is it real
yeah i mean we need more
fermented is it like yeah i think so i
think more fermented foods i mean if you
look at
traditional cultures who tend to eat
more fermented foods they have a
healthier
pickles and kraut kraut and then yeah
we should all be eating kraut yeah i
mean i don't like if you like it
yeah if you don't like it like i don't
eat it because i don't like it but
kombucha
kefir right there's other fermented
foods
fermented it's a good thing fermented
has good bacteria
correct yeah pickles pickles
kefir kombucha uh sauerkraut
roadkill roadkill
um something that is really fascinating
about
you is that when we started talking
i'm a chronic oversharer
um everybody knows this but we started
like we're texting about like medical
stuff and i started going into my like
i'm an allen on and i grew up in a
dysfunctional home and i i'm addicted to
adrenaline and
and like you got it all right away
and it's for me i feel like i feel like
there's this
sort of uh uh deeply like bifurcated
like there's psychiatrists and there's
doctors like
there's physical health and then there's
mental health and there are two separate
things i think that's how it's set up
you're the first person i've ever talked
to that incorporates
both yeah because i think i think for me
where i've experienced the most
where i've been most valuable and i've
had to learn along the way is
to help people with the mindset stuff
big time incorporating that to the
physical stuff right it has to go hand
in hand
and i and i think you know we set it up
there's cardiologists for your heart and
neurologists for your brain and but
that's not how we work like
everything affects everything yeah like
how could it not be
and so it's really doesn't that's why a
lot of pharmaceuticals they were oh just
take this for your cholesterol or just
take this for your mood
it's time i also get that divorce right
it did i mean it's like it's like that
that's what i kept as like
before i moved you know where i live now
and i was in bad relation it's like
i i need to be on an antidepressant and
i need to do this i need to it's like i
just need to break up with that guy
actually you know i think some of it
goes back to that ownership of
um you know just our decisions yeah like
we're gonna make bad decisions and
that's okay yeah and then
again are those decisions made out of
fear are they man from a place of
abundance
like that's a big big thing i think for
people that they don't understand
they're trained we train people for fear
we train people
and in that fear-based system yeah is
the healthcare system which is
disease-based which is if you don't take
this medicine you're not healthy
and think about that like even though it
has 45 side effects
yeah like antidepressants it's literally
a coin toss if it'll work for someone
literally but the placebo effect
is powerful that's real because i was
not i uh
i am on prozac i think i'm going to go
off it soon
but i never thought i was depressed like
that's just not
like i'm yeah i i was i'm like i'm manic
i have too much energy
yeah but like i can't get out of bed i'm
like i can't go to bed you know
right i'm like a spaz and um
but i do have this thing that after like
10 years in allen on and
and like doing the mental work and doing
emdr
eye movement reprogramming and
desensitization and
hypnosis and like doing all of it uh
i sat down uh with psychiatrists and i
was like after i leave a conversation
with someone
i'll um replay it in my head and beat
myself up and like
even it happened out earlier we were
talking downstairs in the kitchen like
we'll be
talking and i'll just like i'll just
start to kind of like
um short circuit and
beat myself up it's like perfectionism
it's like paralyzing it's like
self-sabotage
yeah it's like paralyzing perfectionism
of like i should have said that that was
stupid that was dumb like you're an
idiot
which i i think is an important you know
i'm i'm
very pro idiosyncrasies
uh character defects we call them in
12-step programs i like to call them
superpowers like a lot of these like
things we pathologize are really useful
based on like how you alchemize them or
like how you
um spin it to benefit you you know being
a perfectionist being
um you know quote unquote ocd being like
super detail oriented like it's why i
think i'm
good at stand up and why i've been able
to do what i do
you know but when it starts to become a
liability and when it stops being like a
productive tool
and it starts being something that
actually hurts you like
it's a you know it's taken me a long
time to realize like you know i don't
think i want to fix that about myself
because it actually benefits me in a lot
of ways
you know but um talking to you
like you're the first doctor that ever
like integrated talking about like
childhood trauma
and growing up around you know
borderline personality disorder and what
that does
to the neurochemicals like it's that's
just
a very real thing because i think that's
how we make true progress we've got to
be really authentic
and so a lot of doctors most doctors
they are trained to think about the next
drug right right surgery yeah and they
stop thinking
what's going on between the surgery yeah
like i
family medicine training for me is about
relationships like i really am
interested in getting to know my
patients
like that's what it's about and if i
don't get to know them
and so i used to have this
insurance-based practice where i'd see
patients every seven minutes it's the
only way we can keep up
yeah and i couldn't do it anymore
because i'm not valuable like that
yeah i'm not going to help people i'm
just going to be part of the same system
that gives them
16 different medicine falls lab orders
and see them every three months
that sucks what's the biggest problem
with our medical system
hmm that's a good question
i mean it's so it's so fear-based so
fear-based
you know scares people that if they
don't take this medicine
and i'm not against this i write
prescriptions i think there's a time and
a place
it's not set up for wellness right we're
focused it's a band-aid set up band-aid
most of it's a band-aid yeah stop the
bleeding yeah which is okay if you need
if you have strep throat or you have a
sinus infection you want antibiotics
it's great yeah awesome but if you
really want to help someone who's got
diabetes or heart disease or cancer or
dementia like these medicines aren't
doing it and then they don't give
any credit to your thought process what
you're eating
working out you know quality of life
like i remember
um this patient she developed cancer she
was older
and her grandson used to take her to the
oncologist and she got worse and worse i
remember the type of cancer one day she
came in just for follow-up she's in a
wheelchair and i was like well how's it
going and
grandson said not not good the
chemotherapy is not working
i said well what's what do the
oncologists say is oh it's more
chemotherapy
it's like ah yeah like that's where we
are
and there's a lot of that going on and
you'll talk to people who are diagnosed
with cancer and they say
to their doctor hey what about what i'm
eating and nutrition oh that doesn't
matter
yeah how does that not matter also to me
the stress of going to a doctor
is probably worse for you than whatever
you have
unless it's like cancer or something so
it's like when i have a cold and i'm
like i could go to the doctor like
i'm going to go and i'm going to have to
wait for two hours and i'll do my
insurance and i'm enough to the ladies
and then i'm gonna get it wrong and then
it's gonna cost all this money and then
i have to go wait in line at the rite
aid it's like i'd rather
to me like when i get sick i'm like i'd
rather just kind of ride it out
than go through the rigamarole of our
medical system giving me some pill
that's probably gonna like i mean i'm on
antibiotics now as you guys can tell i'm
not like
operating on like hitting on all
cylinders i'm just like
i'm gonna have to deal with all the side
effects and it's just like
it's so frustrating and probably but i'd
say most people
don't think like you and they run to the
doctor to get the medicine right
because they don't really want to think
of other things right
that'd be too hard for them they don't
want to own it
sugar i think sugar's fine i mean first
it's all about dosage with that right
yeah i mean this whole thing that can't
touch sugar
yeah really it's wild yeah i don't
understand
is it just like we need some kind of
control sense of control or
sense of you know a positive
contribution to our future self like i
don't need sugar that's my thing
i've met many people who say that you
know yeah it's like or do you want a
medal for that like
yeah yeah like it's just like you got a
gold star it's like a self-depriving
yeah sort of like i don't drink caffeine
i don't eat any sugary no gluten it's
like
and caffeine is great caffeine is
awesome obsessed
yeah alcohol i think it goes back to
dose
yeah yeah i think alcohol's fine in
small moderation why are people like
red wine is like good for you
in moderation yeah for sure but is it
like is it the wine that's good for you
the fact that you're relaxing
it's a good question yes yeah that's a
really good question
i would say a lot of it's because you're
relaxed yeah because what you're doing
to your cortisol
where like wine is a couple of glasses
of wine a week is good for you yeah
because you're chilling
right you're probably hanging out with
someone you're making eye contact with
them and you're
depressing yeah like you come home you
look forward to the ceremony
of having a drink and that's okay yes
and that's the ritual
the ritual and you're relaxed you can
regroup i don't think there's anything
wrong with that
problem is when people go and they get
blitzed yeah not great no that's not
ideal
no but are there certain alcohols that
are just like better
uh clear liquor so like tequila vodka
gin
yeah say that's the best yeah wine beer
not so good because of the sugar but
yeah yeah
red wine's better than white wine red
wine's better i get my grades
i used to as well really nad fix that
what yeah so
migraines are i'm i'm gonna get a
migraine talking about
how angry i am about the lack of
research on migraines
because i feel like because it's so
predominantly female
there's just so little research on it
like i remember going on that's my brand
probably true
uh i remember going to a migraine doctor
uh i used to get such bad migraines i'd
have to just go to the er
and i didn't have health insurance at
the time and i just have to get morphine
i was on a list i was on like a
like a drug drug addicts will go into
the er and pretend they have
migraines for it to get morphine exactly
so they'd they check a list and my name
was on a list and i never
i would uh they were so bad the left
uh side of both of my eyeballs when i
lose vision and
lose complicated migraines yeah feeling
i couldn't read like yeah you can sort
of see words
i get the same it's called a scotoma
yeah yeah i get the same thing
i've gotten classical migraines since i
was 13. 12 years i remember
high school i used to take excedrin
every morning because i was scared wow
wow
yeah i was so afraid is being afraid of
getting a migraine
perpetually often perpetuates it yeah
and so
i've been on multiple pharmaceuticals
you know over the years to try
but the one thing that's worked the best
is nad therapy well yeah i mean i went
entire year without a migraine
wow and now i just get the visual or i
don't really get pain anymore
and what do you think it's from when you
get it now i mean it could be a lot of
so in general my greeners need to be
even keel
yep right same amount of sleep eating on
regular it's like the deal with my
grades from what i understand correct me
if i'm wrong i know you will
is like it's about routine whatever you
eat
whether you're drinking hot the same
it's not about if you drink coffee or if
you sleep
well or not it's just do the same thing
all the time
there's certain foods which aren't good
barometric pressure is a big thing
barometric pressure which is yeah i know
what it is but remind me like the
humidity
the tension in the air uh-huh like and
it used to be like
summer i get a lot more migraines
interesting
it's that physical pressure on the blood
vessels on the nerve i would think it's
like pollen or allergies it could be but
and then even like flashing lights
lights oh yeah they've shown that strobe
lights but also straightening
like shouldn't you get your vision
checked definitely straightening can do
it yeah lots of things can do it's any
sort of stress
grinding at night yeah physical stress
chemical stress all that
you feel like we're just a little bit
more frail in that regard right and then
what i do
instantly when i get one now is i do an
imatrex inhaler
okay uh and then watch i
do sparingly i only i don't get
migraines as often now
but i remember when i was doing a tv
show
uh for nbc i was getting such bad
migraines like three times a week
four times a week and then i was taking
like immatrics and rail packs
like all these like medications
medications and they were getting worse
and worse and worse and i was like am i
taking it too late
and then i call the doctor like oh well
if you take two
it too many times a week it actually
causes migraines that's right
like what like this just happened to be
my sinus infection is i was using synax
that um to clear my sinuses
and i was using i used it for like four
or five days and then it was getting
worse and worse worse they're like oh
yeah if you use it too much it's gonna
make it worse it's like why are these
on the market yeah well it just goes
back to the
thing we're talking about where we adapt
to it i mean afrod addiction is like
apparently
a big deal real thing oh yeah yeah where
well it's not really an addiction i
would say
that's probably the wrong word but it's
a tolerance that people get used to it
so they have to keep doing it i don't
read the label
i don't have time yeah i'm not most
people are not reading the label let's
be honest
let's just just be clear so i was like
using the synax
and uh and it just keep getting worse
and worse and worse
yeah so then the thing that you're
taking to fix your ailment
is exacerbating it could be wild
yeah so ridiculous okay so i want to go
back to
um the migraine stuff
yeah uh light sunglasses
working out eating like i i'm hearing
eating a lot of fast they don't want to
eat till dinner but
i can't fast yeah i don't feel good
fasting yeah i think some people can't
fast i mean i've tried it i don't
and i part of it's that lingering fear
of migraines because
when i pass it before yeah it can
trigger it yeah so i don't again does it
slow down your metabolism or no
um i don't think if you're fast uh on a
re no if you're not you want to eat
yeah i mean i i don't here's the thing i
don't think it's as big a deal as we're
making it ought to be
yeah just don't yeah this whole thing
like oh eat from twelve to eight and
that's it like you're gonna extend your
life yeah
i don't really see that happening yeah
but i would i'm open to people
trial and error so if you when you if
you only eat from 12 to eight and that's
great and you feel great
that's information that you should go by
but it shouldn't be for everyone i think
there's this pressure
like i have to intermittent fast to be
healthy i just don't buy into that
i'll tell this story because it ties
into the ketamine so it's good have a
patient work with a lot of them special
forces guys who have a ton of ptsd
and um we've referred this one gentleman
from um
texas who was a helicopter pilot in the
army then weren't worked for the
police department and he was in a bad
helicopter crash
and his partner was killed he was
paralyzed from the knees down
so he was in the intensive care unit in
the hospital his wife could never see
him she never saw him
never because she wasn't allowed in then
her dad
got diagnosed with some terminology she
never saw her dad and then he ended up
dying
so he came to our offices and um to do
nad and ketamine
this last week and uh we combined the
two so we give people
nad intravenously then we give him a
shot academy if they're a good candidate
and the first day he did great had a
great experience
really opened him up a bit kind of get
some clarity and insight
second day had a great treatment as well
and then that was on a tuesday and
around 8 30 at night he called me and he
said i
need help like i can't be by myself and
because his wife wasn't with him
so i went and picked him up and we spent
the night with him and talked him
kind of off the ledge and it was very
helpful for him to ask for help
yeah and that ketamine and the nad
really kind of helped turn things around
what does it kind of
do so technically it's an nmda receptor
antagonist so
when it binds to that receptor it slows
down glutamate
this neurotransmitter glutamate going
across the neurons and glutamate
when people get too much glutamate like
from msg for example
msg is the mono sodium glutamate yeah
it's like excitatory people don't feel
good is that in chinese food chinese
food
people don't feel good so when you slow
down glutamate
you have more insight and clarity into
your thought process yeah
yeah and so it's important because i
think glutamate's the
neurotransmitters that's involved most
in memory consolidation
so whether you're young and developing a
personality or you have you know
traumatic event
those memories are shaped by how
glutamate
interfaces with your nervous system so
when you use ketamine this is my
simplistic view of it
you change how that ketamine that
glutamate is working in your nervous
system so you're able to see things from
a different perspective and
form new memories right that then you
reinforce in a positive way so then that
trauma or stress you literally healed
i mean it's so miraculous
it's things that i have struggled with
for 30 years yeah like
overnight like forgive my mom done
yeah forget like like when i
do the academy and i'm like oh i owe
that person an apology from high school
yeah i should reach out like it's just
like ego
shame and guilt are lifted for me this
is my personal experience
resentments are gone sure the sort of
i didn't realize how much dread i carry
with me like i'm always like waiting for
the other shoe to drop and
i my catastrophic thinking is so
severe that it's always like like just
anticipating the worst case scenario all
the time just dreading
yeah dreading the future getting up
being like oh this again
i mean it's like i've never been
suicidal it's not that i
it's just like oh every even things that
i've worked so hard to achieve and you
get it and then you're just like oh
i have to respond to this email about
this living my dream
like it's just like you know what i mean
it's like it's just never good enough
it's just yeah it's just like nothing's
ever enough like
you know um i can i don't feel like uh
you know we i talk a lot on this podcast
about you know my co-dependence and my
uh you know i think this is nature it's
nurture it's being a woman it's my
conditioning it's growing up around
borderline personality disorder where
you had to people please and
obsess over other people's needs in
order to be safe you had to micromanage
and mother and martyr and you had to be
an adult too soon and you had to like
anticipate people's needs and moods
um you know i used to not have the
ability to tolerate the discomfort of
others
that's sort of like what codependence is
you're mad at me or it's like nothing's
ever enough like got it
i bought you dinner i should have bought
you dinner now do you feel now i feel
weird i shouldn't i didn't
i i tipped 20 oh is that insulting is
that just i tip too much
like just everything is a thing just
nothing is ever
enough yeah nothing's ever over like
it's like
you know there's no peace you do a lot
of things out of obligation you do a lot
this person wants to hang out i'm gonna
go hang out with this person you hang
out with them and you feel like
i should have said that i didn't even
want to be here like i didn't want to
hang out with this person now i'm
beating myself up over not doing a good
enough job hanging out with them and i
didn't want to come in the first place
like just
just like just like a just misery cycle
you go work out to feel better look
better and you're like that workout
wasn't good enough like i didn't i
fucking kind of have asked that workout
why don't you even do that fuck you i go
to the parking lot you're like
like it's just like it never ends it
never ends
and then academy just made me sort of be
like cool i nailed that now
like i just like small wins i just yeah
like i just sort of feel
like kind of psyched about whatever's
happening yeah
well they did a study head-to-head of
ketamine versus an ssri
which is like a prozac pro
paxil and they showed because people are
familiar who take this that
you know those medicines take three to
four weeks to kick in literally right
ketamine's instantaneous to get the same
effect
like that's amazing amazing amazing and
it gets a very bad rap because i think
it's a street drug it's abused yeah
it's abused yeah is that what the
special i've never done special k
well it's kind of no i kind of wish i
had yeah but that that was like like a
super high dose that like paralyzed
people or something i mean people still
do that oh really yeah
i guess it depends on the form the
vehicle how you do it and how much you
do or something
for sure but you could go in now and do
like a session
supervised as well for sure and people
can come to your office and do it
right correct but you're not like fucked
up for the rest of the day
no not how we do it yeah no not at all
you you have this experience we do it as
an intramuscular shot so you have this
experience which lasts about 30 minutes
sometimes 40
maybe yeah and then we have put people
with an eye mask
put certain music on kind of guide the
journey oh nice
yeah and so it's a very interpersonal
keep it quiet in the room no talking
yeah checking on people often and then
they come out and they've
usually it's very cathartic they feel
emotional they've learned some things
they've seen some things
where do you stand on ayahuasca i think
it's a great tool
yeah when used appropriately i don't
think it's a good entry point for people
oh right
yeah like not the first thing it
shouldn't be the first yeah but ketamine
probably is actually because ketamine
gets your
your feet wet into this kind of feeling
out of control
yeah and what i say to a lot of patients
is i work with a lot of high achievers
is
what's gotten you here which is the hard
working and the fighting and the
scrapping and calling
the wisdom actually is to get you there
is probably the surrender the allowance
and the acceptance
yeah and as a society we tend to think
that is weak but it's really not
it doesn't mean you give up it means you
surrender to you're not necessarily in
charge of all this
the alpha sleeps so it's it's it's a
really good entry academy
for lots of great work i don't i've
never done mushrooms
and everyone thinks i'm crazy i did lsd
when i was like 13 and it was did not go
well
yeah uh because i was i'm like was such
a control freak and i was just like
wanted
yeah um and then i tried to do mushrooms
a couple months ago but i just like
didn't have
time like i might i'm such a workaholic
that i can't be a drug addict because
i'm too addicted to my work
because i was like oh i'm gonna have to
like plan it like i could like schedule
it like i just
i couldn't do it like i have them
downstairs but is is
mushrooms a tool another i mean so again
a lot depends on how you're using it
yeah so traditionally those i don't
think i need to expand my
i feel like i'm at a good yeah but a lot
of those i don't want to know anymore
yeah a lot of those tools
got ruined because people were using
them recreationally and just that's not
i mean if you're using them
therapeutically it's very different
yeah yes yes the attention the intention
is huge you're not doing
i think for i think it's this and from
what i know about addiction like
if you're using it to check in and not
check out yeah that's a really good way
of putting it right so it's like if
you're using ayahuasca or mushrooms to
check
out and forget about your problem escape
and anesthetize yourself no good if
you're using it to confront
and to like uh forgive and to explore
like to go into it well like you said so
i think the way that a lot of these work
is
is in with ketamine it allows the ego to
settle down yeah and then you're
able able to get it to explain ego how
would you define i don't know
i don't even know how to define it it's
really challenging from what i
understand
ego is like your f uh what you
project like your defense that comes up
when you're scared
to overcompensate like um
you know it's your shadow it's your like
i don't think all ego is bad though but
i think ego is what drives us to be
achievers
yeah ego is kind of very humanistic yeah
we want materials it has a very negative
pejorative yeah
i agree so it helps us get material
things helps us achieve
yeah whereas you look at something like
our consciousness or spirit
they're much more interested in the
peace and like the kind of betterment of
our consciousness as a whole
right which is not really attached to
ego
it's like uh you read the four
agreements
you kind of yeah the numbers pretended
yeah like number three is don't take
things personally yeah this is a
wonderful statement like
fixes most things that people don't
think things personally but everyone
does
that's the ego you know yeah take it
personally like you
meant that to hurt me or you meant to
you know yeah no
i'm just doing my thing yeah yeah yeah
and so like
life doesn't happen to you it happens
for you
you know it's like it's like if
someone's hurts you they're just
hurting themselves really right they're
just well and probably you invited that
in so you have that interaction so you
can also heal that part of you but a lot
of people
want to be hurt oh for sure like that
it's a weird thing to say
but as someone that used to be addicted
to
self-deprivation and i think being a
victim i think being victimized
gives you is a role that
you probably got honestly like if you
truly were a victim like and it works
for you
oh they have an agent they get something
it's a very comfortable place to be if
you're a victim
like complaining feels good gossiping
the attention feels good being um
beat up on feels kind of good sometimes
complain you know
yeah i had this i i think of this i had
this patient this couple years ago and
he had this chronic reactivation of
epstein-barr virus which is rare but it
happens
and referred to me for some iv therapy
and i said let's do nad because i want
you to feel better before we start
tackling the bigger things disabled
depressed not working for years
we did five nad treatments one week
later came back in the office with his
wife she's crying so my husband's back
he's excited
i said this is awesome let's continue
this they said oh no no no we're good
we're going to try something else which
was that same victim like you enjoy
being the victim you're getting
something interesting
and i see that it's also just like is
change is hard i mean it's like when you
ask someone how they're doing oh
i'm so tired i'm just saying nightmares
like
no one's ever like i'm good right like
you know what i mean it's just like it's
it's also not like cool to be okay
now it's very in vogue to like be sick
everyone true you know everyone needs to
have like an
allergy or like a lyme disease or like
that's true
you know to be there's it's also very
involved to be
sick and have a diagnosis to have a
diagnosis like a
like i've been in trouble for this but
it's like like this anxiety thing
everyone's got anxiety like yes
of course but you should have it
it'd be weird to not have anxiety right
now well
yes and no like like not
an unuseful anxiety but like
yes we're in a pandemic yes the election
was very stressful
we're on our phones look what the news
the news
makes money off of scaring the shit out
of us like they're just trying to
they're slot machines now they're just
trying to keep us addicted to go back to
refreshed
right i mean the words they use like
like
you know friend of mine is um uh
whatever
who cares if they're my friend that's
this famous person like responded to
someone on twitter that was shitty to
them
that was just like you know i don't like
a show and she was like
cool or i just like responded like so
and so
claps back so and so slams like they
pick
words intentionally that you know
and then you read the article it's like
is your drinking water killing your
children
click here and you're like i guess you
know it's just like so stressful
um but i just feel like there's a little
bit of
you know i think in terms of like
survival of the fittest and what
helped our species proliferate like the
most anxious
people were probably the ones that were
able to procreate the ones that were
able to survive
right like we got this anxiety honestly
i don't i don't know i mean i think
there's there's a time and a place for
anxiety
like if it's protective like i don't
think the stuff we're being anxious
about
we really need to be anxious about it's
obsolete but
like our brains haven't evolved to know
how
safe we are now right yeah i mean i
think it ties in back to that cortisol
thing yeah you know and i think for a
lot of people anxiety comes from
not being able to keep up with yeah
secreting cortisol appropriately yeah
most of us will never have to deal with
a life or death stress like we think
primitively like
living and oh your neighbor got eaten by
lying in the jungle like a
literal you know legitimate concern for
you most of us will never deal with that
but we're operating the same kind of
biological mechanisms when we're stuck
in traffic
yeah listening to the news or something
and so that whole process i think is
modulatable i think you can change that
i think what i see is that people aren't
empowered to know that they can actually
do whatever they want
yeah you can change all of your thought
process
if you practice right i think it ties
back to the victim but we've been
toned down so much that people don't
even believe that they have the choice
in that
yes but they do it's 100 you can
change anything you want and it's also
really important i think
like the emotional contagion of the
people you surround yourself with for
sure
like i hope people
after listening to this podcast like
block a couple of motherfuckers on their
phone
like they're you cannot be around people
that are addicted to anxiety and stress
and not have that rub off right well
it's like i tell people that there's
only been one thing that's been shown to
help every single type of cancer
it's positivity well that's it
so for people who are diagnosed with
cancer but it shouldn't just apply to
them right
because cancer is really a wake-up call
if you're diagnosed with cancer a lot of
it goes back to those toxic
relationships that you're
harboring yes and buying into and guilt
and like the shame and you will never
get out of it
hopefully it's a wake-up call like i
don't have time for any negativity
yeah and i think people are so and
we talk about a lot but like addicted to
toxic relationship it's so hard to see
that you have a choice like it's
so hard to break up with a friend it's
so hard to cut off a brother or sister
or like a mob or whatever you know i
mean it's just so hard but it's like i
always just say like you gotta get off
the dance floor
like it's like you do have a part in a
toxic relationship like 100 if you're
blaming and you're
well this person keeps calling me well
you keep answering i don't get in life
what you tolerate i
yeah nothing changes if nothing changes
and but i think people are afraid of
being just
really real about it yeah and they are
like and also i think
something that helps i think for people
to go it's so mean that to cut off this
toxic person like
the only way i was able to do it was to
reframe it as like you're actually
helping a gift
yeah because you're giving them a
consequence right you're giving them as
opposed to enabling them it's very
passive
yes you're like it's like a dog's
peeking on the carpet a hundred times
the hundred first time you're like why
are you being on the carpet it's like
well you never
you know it's like it was okay i thought
it was okay yes yeah
so i just so many people i know are just
in these like toxic relationships that
take such a toll on their physical and
mental health and it's just like
you know i think we you no amount of
supplements no amount of exercise is
going to fix that
toxic relationship but i think what can
like we talked about is figuring out how
to empower people to understand that
everything that happens in life
is a choice right and you got to own it
and if it's bad own it still
also owning it like it doesn't mean you
have to stop it
it just means you own it it's actually
you know i think for me because i always
got my
self-esteem or my um
or uh sort of comfort from blaming other
people because a lot of people dropped
the ball when i was you know it's very
easy to blame your mom and blame your
dad and blame your
you know blame like my ex and my this
and my boss and whatever
and uh because that means i get to be
perfect yeah you know but there's
something
so empowering about taking
responsibility
and just going oh well that's on me
right it's such a relief
because you're like oh shit i actually
have some control over this yeah it's
like
garyvee i heard a quote he said take
responsibility for every single thing in
your life and watch
what happens it's like it's amazing a
miracle it's amazing the empowerment
that comes from when you own
every single thing that's my fault oh my
god that was my fault yeah
i'm so sorry that was totally my fault i
had yeah i should have said that right
i should have done that yeah it's like
and there's nowhere to go from there
it's like but i think for a lot of
people myself included like there's this
hard-wired shame about
doing anything wrong or imperfect
or be you know admitting fault we were
talking before we started this about
you know generational things yeah
ancestral things and there's these
patterns and they're
very wired they're very real it's
very challenging for people to break
yeah these these family dynamics and
patterns that
then we're just raising the same thing
over and over and people are becoming
less empowered over time
yeah in part because the media and
they're just reading headlines they stop
critically thinking
yeah but it takes a lot of work for most
people to understand it like no you can
change that pattern
yeah and that pattern breaking that
pattern is monumental i mean the
ancestral
trauma that we carry it's it's real uh
it is so i mean it imprints on our dna
like the guilt the shame it does
and it's hard to say like does it all
come from our genes does it all come
from
how we're raised it's certainly a
combination yeah it has to be a
combination but it's passed down
you know if you expose a young child i
mean they say that the majority of our
personalities formed before they were
five years old wow the majority of who
you will be and how you react to
the world for the rest of your life
starts before you're
10 before you're 15 it's 5 years old wow
so
those experiences are critical we don't
seem to have control over them because
we're too young
but then when we can look back when
we're older and say okay i can modify
how i respond and understand that like
this is a pattern that's
happened to my mind right like it's
happening to my parents and their
parents and
i don't want to be a part of that and i
i i think there's a little bit of like
guilt in uh breaking it
of going like i'm not sure you're not
rejecting them they didn't want it
either
like you're just the first generation
shining a light yes
we're the first generation that's like
you know what that's an
obsolete tool like you know what that
served
my grandmother really what the guilt and
shame cycle served my grandmother really
well in the depression but like don't
need that now
right you know i think there's a little
bit of guilt about evolving and growing
especially because you know as we say in
12-step programs when you get healthy
the sick and angry
you know like people don't like it when
you get better your family
is not going to like it when all of a
sudden you have boundaries and
self-respect and high self-esteem and
aren't
in that role that they've cast you in
because when you're not
when you stop being a doormat people
don't like it
so so talking about some like ketamine
or ayahuasca what
what they do literally is they help you
have compassion yes
yes that's right that's right it helps
you have compassion for these negative
things
and that and that is so critical because
it doesn't mean you have to like them
uh-huh but if you can have compassion
for what they went through
and how they treated you then you're
actually going to be able to pass that
forward and change
change the whole paradigm like it's so
instant i've spent so much time
trying to forgive people and release
resentments these crystallized
resentments and anger
which i know at a conscious level is so
unhealthy like i know it's like
being mad at somebody you know
is drinking poison and waiting for the
other person to die i know that
consciously but it's so hard to not
hold those resentments it was like the
ketamine thing is the first thing that i
just was like oh
god bless his heart right poor thing
he was doing the best he could with the
tools he had that's all of us it
actually made me feel like i was the
bully
in most of these situations because i
was so impatient
with the um lack of tools this person
had in their toolbox
why would my dad have any ability
right to like like uh
be you know leave it to beaver and i'm
trying to think of a perfect
stick up yeah mayberry like
and i'm also now so grateful for the
adversity i had because it gave me all
these i'm like
have all these like weird superpowers
because
yes because i'd adapt so young right you
know
so it just it makes every it makes
everything good news yeah
everything's good news but but tonight
didn't get that job
great now i'm gonna get this other job
and if i got that job i wouldn't have
gotten this like it's just like
but to be honest everything is good yeah
that but i didn't understand yeah
like it it just is and then once you
understand that like all the anxiety can
go away like
yeah i'll get covered but i'll be okay
but i'll be fine yeah
and yeah these people are annoying the
hell out of me but it's it's okay
because i understand that
they're in a really tough situation and
like it's all practice like i could
hear i could especially like you know
this is coming out around the holidays
like people were
it is so
wild how quickly i could time travel
to being like a teenager a bratty
teenager around
family members like it's just like like
you walk in the door it's like
boom what the fuck like you're just like
why are you like
they don't you know they for our family
members we're kind of frozen in time for
that yeah
you know for sure and when i go back
into uh family circumstances
and they still treat me like i'm a kid
or
young it makes me feel so invisible
and misunderstood when i feel
misunderstood and visible like i just
get
so mad i just get so frustrated and i
feel so alone and so angry
and then you start to like
convince them that you're an adult which
is super childish and then you start
sort of feeding into what they already
see because you're being petulant and
being like well i'm
successful and like how could you not
have seen that like you know
it's just like a nightmare right instead
of just
like going to my elders really like
what was it like for you in college like
just like getting
information from them like that's a good
point like asking them
questions like that's my new approach
with like difficult people
it's just like or go back to not taking
it personally be an anthropologist yeah
they do this to everyone
they're actually just trying to make
conversation with you they're trying to
probably usually when people are meeting
you they're trying to be funny right
which is the other thing
or they're just like you know insecure
or rambling or just
bombing really yeah and my thing is just
ask them questions about themselves
you're go you're gonna benefit you're
gonna learn something and ultimately
people just wanna talk about themselves
that's true no that's a really good
tactic that's like my whole tactic
of difficult people yeah where do you
live where did you come from right
understanding yeah yeah where are you
from originally where did it
yeah and it and it triggers me like in
medical school they did the study they
stood outside doctor's offices and they
collected the trash to look at what the
prescriptions were thrown away and they
found like
35 percent of prescriptions are thrown
away every day
from patients going to see the doctor
and people are like well why is that
didn't they want to go and get a
prescription
no what people really want is just to be
heard oh my gosh
and it's very true like that's not what
people want they don't want
prescriptions
i think that's the same with prostitutes
yeah a lot of prostitutes um
say that uh they'll like go to the room
and the person just really wants to talk
what's the talk wants to be listened to
when you understood wants to be
validated yes
people need validation but i think the
key is if you can have validation for
yourself
and say like yeah i forgive myself i'm
doing the best i can yeah
life gets so much easier and then um
unless you're dealing with someone who
has a personality disorder
personality disorders are tough like we
talked about they're not modifiable
right technically so if you've got
borderline like you brought up
borderline is
they love you until they hate you and
then borderline is can you just
your definition of borderline borderline
is it's
um it's love hate like it flips
yes according to how they feel yes this
is extremism and does this come from
a trauma or is it inherited borderline
personality
so i think there's genetic
predisposition for all the stuff right
right but then i think it's a setup for
development right right so the way i
think about it some milestone wasn't met
right right like they weren't hugged
enough they weren't seen enough eye
contact enough yeah whatever it is it
wasn't met and so they had to escalate
somehow in a kind of on a sideways way
to kind of fulfill that
to make it okay for them yeah and so
probably it's a lot of self-worth things
i think
yeah like people don't when they look in
the mirror they really hate themselves
yeah
and so then they're projecting that on
others yeah because what they really
want is that hug
to be validated like you're good how you
are but there's this great that there's
a great book i think it's called walking
on eggshells
about how to deal with borderline
personality disorder and it's like
like i know i'm dealing with someone
that has borderline personality sort of
i
if i instantly start um being anxious
and uh like complimenting them
and like worrying about it just i just
instantly start to make myself small
and minimize myself i won't like talk
about work or anything good that's going
on with me like i
instantly start and then i'm like oh god
that this is happening
right it's just like i at a different
frequency with borderline they just make
me
um scared and they feel like authority
figures to me right away
the people that when they they call and
you're like oh do i answer
you know because you never know what
you're gonna get
you don't know the mercurial nature of
the borderline
it's like it's it's super challenging
and any type of uh
self-care on your part feels like a
rejection to them
right yeah i i understand that
yeah and there's a lot of i mean so
people can have uh personality traits
yeah which is different than a disorder
yeah
i mean how do you like know if someone's
borderline i think it's just a clinical
thing
yeah how they feel they're very hot and
cold yeah
i get concerned when i see patients who
are overly complementary
like you don't need to compliment me to
the end of the earth like it's
interesting
right because that's what i get
concerned about because i know on the
other side of that
if i don't answer your message and as
soon enough time that you yeah yep yep
i'm the devil it comes with the price it
does and that's what i get considerably
like oh my gosh you're the greatest
people are two nights too much like i
just met you and you're saying i'm the
the best doctor in the world it's like
you you don't know that and i don't i
feel like i did that
no i don't need to i don't need to i
asked my therapist if i was borderline
once and she was like borderlines
usually don't come to therapy and ask if
they're borderline
i was like my narcissist she's like
narcissists don't come to therapy and
ask if they're narcissistic
there's a bunch of i mean borderlines
tend to be cutters so they'll try to you
know
get attention by cutting their wrists
things like that right right right
it's complicated but they say but it is
also like
borderlines make you feel like you're
crazy
that's how convenient they challenge you
that's how confusing it is
like you really start to think that
you've done something wrong yeah
sociopaths are the same way i mean
associated with sociopathic psychopaths
uh sociopath that's a good question i
think sociopaths are the ones who are
like chameleons
yes right and they take on like they can
really like
they're very charismatic yes and they
like take on the personality of the
person
yes yes mirror them they mirror them and
they're really good sales people
like they're the best because they can
just yes get inside your head and make
you feel like oh but they lack empathy
they lack there's no empathy right yeah
so it's
they're the probably the hardest to deal
with i think well what's you
there's no well said they say they say
if it's a personality story there's no
treatment like because it's so ingrained
in their personality right like you
can't get them back
yeah you can just kind of try to guide
them and then when you're dealing
uh is it true that
the higher level of success like echelon
you're in the more
sociopaths there are probably because
they're very high performing
very successful like a lot of the people
that
have a lot of followers on instagram
that are very successful in their
business
like entrepreneurs silicon valley i'm
generalizing but like a lot of these
people that are kind of running the
world
well then a lot of them have that
narcissism too uh-huh and then you can
have a narcissistic sociopath
that right and then swipe right the
narcissistic
is yeah the world my twenties yeah the
world revolves around them yep
like there's how you can't they cannot
conceive
and there's no there's no dealing with
the narcissist there's no
you're just banging your head against
the wall yeah you just got it well i
think it's just understanding who what
you're dealing with yeah and then trying
to you know kind of just corral them in
different ways
is it true that um narcissists
are specifically narcissistic or
boastful
uh ego binonical whatever it is about uh
whatever they think they're great at or
the best at or
you know based on what their parents
didn't approve of i don't know i i i
i've like va
i've read this i go to like i'm very
into narcissists
and i did like a deep dive on them and i
read something somewhere about like
if someone thinks they're like the best
athlete it means like their dad didn't
think they were good enough athletes
like it's to overcompensate it's
definitely overcompensating they project
the image that their parents would have
approved that could be
yeah there's something interesting i
just think it it seeps into every aspect
of their life
like they have to talk about themselves
it can't there's no way they're asking
questions
it's all about them they can't conceive
of a world where they're not the very
best
it's so damaging to their psyche
the idea of not being the star the
center of the world
like it's so damaging to them they
cannot tolerate it literally
but there's a difference between being
confident and having
high self-esteem and knowing your worth
and being a narcissist and i think it's
hard to tell
delineate sometimes because i think
there is this new generation that's
going like yeah i should speak up i
should lean in
like i am good at this like and
it's easy to conflate that with them
well i think narcissisms they can't be
humble right like that's just a good
measure
right and they ha like you said there's
no empathy yes there's just not
one way street it's all about them all
the time
what are like the biggest myths in
wellness culture
like the biggest like the most fooly
like charcoal toothpaste taking charcoal
are we taking charcoal
i mean i don't i don't know much about
charcoal put me on the spot there
yeah well i mean if you don't know about
it it's probably not
there's probably i mean it's hard to say
there's there's like if you dive into
like the history of like
healing modalities yeah there's a lot of
really things that don't make sense
yeah and a lot of it is a deliberate
effort of the pharmaceutical mainstream
medicine to quiet those
yeah so like for example like people
don't realize but
in the tombs of many egyptian mummies
they found
all these botanical herbs like licorice
root which was like
5 000 years old other ones that don't
taste good even
in neanderthal grave sites they find
these botanical herbs and in you know
like ayurveda like using ashwagandha has
a historic in the historical record for
thousands of years
so these things are really to me that's
information that
these things work yeah they're passed
down for thousands years yeah but if you
read
you know the mainstream medicine they
say oh they haven't been tried in a
study like this is all bullshit
right like they're not a drug how dare
we you know if it's not a drug
but you could apply that acupuncture
people say to traditional chinese herbs
yeah
there's a there's a lot of these
modalities which actually have a really
strong basis
acupuncture works acupuncture can work
yeah i don't think anything works for
everybody
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm a big fan of
trial and error like cause to me it's
like acupuncture it's like the stress of
going to the appointment
like kind of like undoes the hole but
you wouldn't think that if you if you
went there and you had a good experience
yeah and then you saw the results you're
like okay
yeah i mean it's not i think it's some
of its expectation like if you go and
you think it's going to make you super
well and yeah
yeah there's mismatched expectations
there
but i think so i think we're speeding up
because of social media with all these
different things people are trying or
claiming is the next best thing there
really is no next best
yeah yeah there just isn't so you can
you could argue for against anything you
want
yeah right and i just say just try it
all yeah like how are you gonna know
unless you try it
it's gonna be it's like there's no
panacea for everybody
it can't be blood type i don't know
enough about it the blood type diet
though doesn't make a ton of sense
yeah you know they're even saying blood
type with covid like
certain blood types are protected maybe
yeah the problem with this is humans
we're so many variables and we can never
control for all the variables right so
if you
people are looking at these right that's
right so you refuse to simplify
something
okay that's what's so interesting about
it we're similar in this way i think
like
you refuse to generalize
or simplify yeah but people just want
i think i think for the most part we'd
rather just be lied to just tell me it
doesn't even have to be
the blood type okay type a i'm more
susceptible like got it like
we just kind of want a false sense of
security so bad that's tough
and i think like the the people that i
trust are the ones that are like
sometimes like it's too it's just we
don't have enough information
you know but it's it's very
disorganizing for us the way i think
about it is
every single thing is made up yeah every
single thing you learn everything is
made up and people say well no there's
things that are fact
not really because if you think about
let's take for example a revolutionary
war like
did this happen well this may have
happened but it was interpreted by
someone someone that was
right through their lens of the world
who recorded that who's passed down
through someone reading that and it's
through their lens yeah that gets passed
down
everything is subjective every single
thing so once you understand that
oh fucking true so every single thing is
made up yeah so the only thing that
matters is everything's gossip basically
every all history's gossip yeah so what
matters most is what you feel about it
yeah
and once people understand it's very
empowering be opinionated make a choice
on something
does it feel true yeah i mean does it
feel right and you may be wrong you may
go down that path say oops
but you're trying it and you're open to
it we do have a biological need to know
be s no stuff to be know-it-alls
i wear this um little wristband because
i take a blood thing medicine now
so two months ago i was diagnosed with
these blood clots in my liver veins
right
out of the blue fluky didn't see it
coming was hospitalized for several days
and one of the main lessons i learned is
like nothing is guaranteed like i
am in really good health yeah this was
not on my radar yeah
i was throwing this massive curveball
yeah and so one of those lessons is
i don't want to just live in a state of
anxiety fear and worry
well it doesn't prevent because it help
like at all yeah like so i want to make
the most of everything which is going to
be
positivity yeah abundance like life is
always working out
yeah because that's a choice that is a
choice
the thing that sort of made 12-step
programs like really stick for me
because i kind of couldn't
i couldn't like lock in for a little
while the going and the people
and the people were eating and they're
shaking up salad things
and like i just people be just
uh nervated me so much when i first went
and i didn't have
like radical compassion yet and i wasn't
like
curious about people like i just
everyone just
like triggered me i was like so obsessed
with
being i was so drunk on like
self-righteous indignation and
criticizing and judging
that it was like um but the serenity
prayer
uh they say at the end of the meetings
and i'd always leave before the end
and then finally i like stayed one time
probably because there was like a cute
guy there or something i want to flirt
with like some unhealthy reason i stayed
and it's um
grant me the serenity to accept the
things i cannot change the courage
to change the things that i can and the
wisdom to know the difference
yeah and you like once that really
landed it was like
oh yeah just focus on the things you can
control like
recently my uh
not trying to equate your health thing
with a dog no it's okay i hate when
people do that no no it's
when my daughter died everyone was like
my ferret's sick and i'm like not the
same problem
very different so i'm not trying to do
that but it's not good it was like
i could not be more obsessive about my
dogs health i could not i mean anyone
listening to have kids like
you bubble wrap your home like all you
do and he
like a freak accident ripped his leg
open tore an artery
three tendons and it was like
that the one thing i could like the one
time i wasn't looking at you like i
it was just freak like there's no way i
could have controlled it there's no
preventative couldn't couldn't have
worrying about it
i worried about so many other things for
no reason and then that happened it's
just like accepting that
freak shit is gonna happen and you're
gonna get through it and you're gonna
adapt
yeah and then it's a choice yeah of how
you respond like you're gonna survive
for sure it's gonna happen but i think
the the
if we can take away the like fear of the
anticipation of the imminent
well that goes back to which a lot of
people try to meditate for is they just
trying to be present
yeah because most of anxiety is either
you're living or focusing on
the past or the future where life only
happens literally one
second at a time one moment probably
another moment that's all you have
control over
how can you ever because when you do
when you're 10 seconds ahead 10 weeks
ahead
that's putting tension on a nervous
system it just has to
because you're worried about something
so that tension
is very real you know just think of that
tension you're pulling on your nervous
system
because you're not bracing for impact i
feel like we're generally just bracing
for impact yeah
all the time all the time i think it's
gotten so much worse this year
what should we just never eat soy
it's always dangerous jesus christ yeah
i'm not gonna say never but it's it's uh
it's anti-nutrition
it's anti-nutritive it flames the fire
of estrogen
we're exposed to way too many estrogens
in our environment from
pesticides herbicides women have
estrogen-related cancers men
need more testosterone not more estrogen
so it's bad for the thyroid
it's just it's not good wow yeah and
then people are having all these soy
lattes and
soy lattes and a lot of the a lot of
people i think think they're being
healthy by doing the plant-based soy
meats
and it's just pure soy oh and it's all
genetically modified
fuck yeah fuck you that though you knew
that shit
it's like whack-a-mole you solve one
problem and it's like causes a whole
other problem
true fuck yeah but don't eat soy or if
you do have soy sauce do it you know
sparingly
stretching you gotta stretch
i guess some do i don't really
i love you you're my favorite
i don't know like um sana
yeah big fan gotta do it oh yeah we we
have my wife now we have a sauna gotta
do the sauna
we love heat shock proteins yeah we just
love it what does it do
it's a stressor like it's a heat stress
it causes good stress to your body yeah
because and it's not necessarily the the
thing with the sauna or cold plunge it's
not the actual temperature
it's the change in temperature so it's
the sizing well it's also the rising of
the temperature and then the fall of the
temperature and that change
is really beneficial we want stress we
want to challenge our systems
but yeah we love our sauna it's the best
purchase we've ever made because you can
do
uh there's these ones you can get for
your garage that are like small
or i mean people if you're allowed to go
to gyms now you know
steam yeah i think i think that's good
but sauna infrared sauna i mean it's a
game changer
infrared see that i'm not doing infrared
maybe that's my problem well infrared's
going to get you know penetrate tissue
at different
levels so it's very anti-inflammatory so
i'm doing hot sauna that's good too
which is what's better i mean depending
on how you use them
i would if you're putting
yeah yes hot sauna's good also it's
really good
you can't go wrong blue light glasses
are you doing them
i don't my wife does yeah yeah yeah
helpful yeah you have trouble sleeping
and
you know you're allowing that
stimulating light and you block it yeah
that makes sense yeah to me
and if you wake up put a blue light on
so you can start you know
enhancing what's going on your brain is
there anything women need to be taking
that men don't need to be taking
in terms of those supplements that's a
good question
yes women are more challenging just
because of the cycling information
personality yeah just everything but
it's more difficult in general but women
have to deal with thyroid issues men
don't have to deal with yeah
with estrogen issues men have to deal
with um
you know i don't know if there's a
particular supplement dea
d ata
i was told to take that at some point i
think it can be good
it also can be bad you know the problem
with the ata is going to convert into
estrogen
oh no and so if you have someone and
most women don't need more estrogen
yeah men don't have more estrogen way
enough yeah so then it becomes a
challenge
i mean it's it couldn't you know what we
like to do is individualize it for
people everybody's different
there's no i do not like generic
statements like yeah this is good
because you could all frame it it's all
how you frame it nutty pots
that's good yeah yeah just cleaning your
sinuses out with salt water
and then add some sodium bicarbonate to
it what's that baking soda
it kind of helps to breed and you do it
every day i don't no
i don't have sinus i don't have sinus
issues i don't have allergies if you
have sinus issues i think it's a great
thing to do because it's like a physical
yeah
yeah yeah i never thought i had sinus
issues
oh now you do oils what oils are you
doing
coconut olive like to cook with yeah um
because olive is bad if it's heated up
too much yeah it's a low flash point
no it's true i know yeah the best
cooking oils are coconut grape seed
walnut oil very high flash points
they're stable you can so you can cook
them at high temperature olive oils
you shouldn't cook with olive oil cold
right cold oil
olive oil is only good cold correct best
cold
yes you can dip things in that's true
i know
i mean these are people are like
whatever what's like the what's the
uh no this is the i want to get really
granular about this kind of shit
this is what this is like i'm asking you
all the shit
that i would want okay no go for it if i
could talk to you
for fucking two hours for free okay
people just want to know like sure
checklist yep
salad dressing
this is salad our salad is good
people say that salad is the worst thing
you can get a restaurant
because of the calories of the dressing
i don't know i mean you go to russia
what do you order
i intend to eat a lot of animal protein
yeah i think yeah meat
chicken you're not gonna get a salad
with blue cheese dressing
i don't i'm not blue cheese no because
of the migraines but yeah but i use
other dressings
okay i'm not afraid of food yeah ever
interesting never why would you be
afraid of what you're eating yeah
you know what i mean like what oh i
can't have blue because it's sick
i'm never going to be afraid of what i
mean sick yeah no it is a sickness
we have created this adversarial
relationship with food
no it is your wife is laughing
one of the first we went on a date one
of the first things she tells me is that
she says i don't trust people that don't
eat
and i was like it's weird right
especially guys it doesn't say
especially men eating disorders
men who are on diets i'm sorry it's so
unattractive yeah men who are on diet
oh my god like what are you doing i know
cutting couch i know
you're fast oh you're paleo grey i guess
we're never gonna have sex my vagina's
just
dried up i kid you i'm so sexist it's
the
when guys are like what's this
yeah it's not what it's just like it's
it is it's wussy to be a guy's hanger in
the diet
the dressing on the side oh my god right
can i get my eggs frozen because we're
never gonna procreate
it's such a bummer but i mean
it's also just such a waste of our life
we're just wasting like
i remember busy when busy phillips was
on we was on we talked about this
that she's seven times like i mean and
women in food like look we get it
honestly
you know we have such a fucked up
relationship with food and are taught to
fear it and hate it and hate our bodies
and you know
not be able to enjoy food and punish
ourselves with food
um and even if we do have good food we
have to feel guilt afterwards
but she said something that really kind
of changed my mindset when i was uh
having major eating disorders she was
like having a bagel or something and we
were like shooting a movie and she was
like in a bathing suit or something and
i was just like how did like what's
going on with like how do you just
and she was like i think about myself on
my deathbed
whenever i get weird about food and i
just think like that i'm gonna look back
and go
i can't believe how much time i wasted
obsessing about
calories like i don't want to be lying
on my deathbed thinking like i wasted so
much time
there's so much people so many people
waste so much time
but that food is just one thing yeah
fitness is another
yeah so many things we have hang-ups on
yeah like it's
totally unnecessary yeah
like we've created this really bad
dynamic sick
yeah it's a sickness yeah and people
make so much money off of it
that's part of the problem diet foods
and proteins protein bars
right they're candy bars they're candy
bars
for the most part they're candy bars
yeah i think there's probably some good
ones
there i mean it's like red number five
sugar and caramel
it's a snickers bar yeah for the most
part
but i mean again drinking collagen does
nothing
no thank you no
most of the supplements don't really do
anything yeah i mean yeah let's be real
yeah no i know i just don't this is what
i
say they just don't like people get hung
up like oh yeah i'm taking
all the all that like i had a patient
who started a couple weeks ago
and he sent me his supplement list which
was three pages long
in a backpack and i said i don't i don't
know if
we're gonna be able to do this because
that's part of your problem
yeah like the stress of that yeah
totally sucks
like for you to be hyper vigilant about
everything going on with you
that's really a problem that's so much
work like what are you eating
yeah are they even absorbing probably
not
yeah we think oral supplements twenty
percent that's it you only absorb about
twenty percent
yeah wild and a lot of them have like
dyes and chemicals and shit
most plastic like are you what are
what's it made out of
right like when i take a supplement i'm
like isn't it aren't i eating tupperware
yeah like what is this yeah is it weird
that we just swallow pieces of plastic
because they're healthy no it's true
people do that with pharmaceuticals
it's crazy no it is but so many people
just
but what is it well that's what goes
back to the sound remember those toys
when you were a kid where you put a
little pill in water and like a
dinosaurs sponge i'm like what is on the
pill
no but most people will never ask that
question they'll just say i'm supposed
to do this
yeah what do you think about it it's
trash
yeah i'm taking this for that and they
have no idea what am i going to take to
make this pill
not kill me right right right what's in
the pill is probably just cancelling out
what's
on the outside of the pill that's true
it's true total negation
yeah you just fixed the whole supplement
industry so
dumb there's so much yeah stupidity
but i mean that's again people kind of
buy into that too any other major myths
that drive you crazy
any of the things that drive you nuts
when people like come in and they're
like
hmm that's a good question we don't we
get a lot of questions about any
air purifiers i think i'm sure there's
vaporizers they're good like what's the
number one thing that you're like oh
that's such a scam
i've seen those um those foot ionizing
baths where people say like
draws off all this black like do you
know what i'm talking about
they're like oh detoxing through your
feet cupping
i think cupping can work for people in
very specific local areas yeah
yeah i'm not colonics i don't know
nothing yeah
i don't understand we lived for
thousands of years without
putting things up our butt right like i
don't understand like i'm going to clean
out the intestines
yeah i did colonic once and it was like
it's it's
so traumatizing it's so someone puts a
hose in your asshole
the guy that i went to was this doctor
i'll tell you
off air his name i think he's dead
which is not a great sign uh yeah
he's doing a lot of course he was an
aquitarian and slept upside down
got it he literally slept he
inverted he
[Laughter]
i'm so glad i found you i was lost for
so long
you were close to sleeping in virginia
what he would do is he would
make a treadmill go on an incline and
then sleep
sleep on an upside down and i was like
okay
i truly was like all right i guess i'm
gonna go to the gym and sleep
sleep at the 24-hour fitness like
i was like the first like real like
doctor i went into in la
and he told me i couldn't eat tomatoes
he told me i could only eat things that
were indigenous to the area that my
ancestor was from
interesting i said to him once i wrote
about this in my book
i said to him once um you know what if
i'm like at the airport or something and
i don't know
there's not something to eat and i just
like grab a banana he was a banana
you might as well put a gun in your
mouth
and then pretty extreme he wanted to do
colonics
uh every week and i went in and i did
the first one
and it's like he puts a hose in your
butt and you feel like you're pooping
it's like the weirdest feeling
to and then water goes up right over and
over again
and then it starts to come out and you
start just seeing your poop and you're
like
i feel like i could have just poked that
out later yeah yeah like i'm not sure
why
you're they say they're cleaning it i'm
like what are you cleaning and then he's
like talking to me the whole time and
like name dropping he's like yeah
jessica alba didn't take as long as you
did i'm like what
this is so wildly inappropriate yeah
it was it was it was very crazy i'm glad
i said kalani not a fan
not a fan enemas i don't even think i
know what an animal is
same type of thing but you just do it at
home yeah why do people want to put
things in their butt so fat
that's a good question
all right i have much more things on
here but i feel like i'm
keeping you comically long keep going
the things that i wrote down here i just
write i'm just right neti pots
yeah stretching soy milk
um uh computer screens
um not great yeah but it's also like to
me it's like
it's about what's on it like everyone's
like cell phones are bad instagram's bad
it's like well who are you following
i think you're probably following i
think it's about balance yeah
like you you who for people say don't
use yourself and that's just stupid
yeah like of course we're going to use
ourselves but don't use it 23 hours a
day yeah yeah
yeah it's about moderation i'm so bad at
moderation yeah and
we all fall guilty to it and it's okay
yeah we're gonna be fine
yeah it's literally okay so
wow hashtag ketamine
it's a it's a really you know i have
conversations with people about every
week it's been life-changing
life-changing life-changing for sure but
the pharmaceutical companies will never
allow it to be
well no they have their own version oh
so they have the new ketamine nasal
spray that's coming out
it's like a like a variant of ketamine s
ketamine that's supposedly better
which will cost several hundred dollars
just more expensive for people and it's
like oh
this is the best but yeah not really
yeah so
but in truth yeah pharmaceutical
companies don't like market share being
taken
or it's against their game plan business
plan for people to do really well
right not trying to be cynical it just
seems like yeah
that's right data blockers beta blockers
are okay
yeah for what my producers think i've
been saying
i mean they already know i'm insane yeah
i mean beta bloggers should be good
medicine i take better blockers
sometimes
for what i'm saying well it's i i was
prescribed beta blockers for
when i uh think a migraine is coming on
i get so anxious i get so worried i'm
gonna get a migraine that i take it to
nip it in the bud yeah i think that can
be good it's good for like it just stops
adrenaline basically for people that get
nervous have to make a public speech or
if you have to do a presentation
it just takes like it's peripheral does
it make you high i don't like xanax or
any of that shit
it's um just sort of peripheral anxiety
all it does is take away
adrenaline yep so i can be good yeah
okay good nothing wrong with that
well i feel healthier do you have any
questions
for me do you need do you need any
of your medical history for me my
medical history is a fucking mess
yeah i yeah i didn't even
i did the broca test okay i don't have
it i failed
that's that's that's a good that's good
news yeah yeah that's good news because
ovarian cancer does run into uh my
family yeah
i mean i mean genetic testing's tough i
mean there's some things that's good for
most things not i think it's somewhat
scammish right right right right i
really do
yeah man
all these people doing like all these
genetic tests saying okay i should eat
this way work out this way
yeah i don't think anything who what do
they stand to gain
well i just think the science is very
early yeah
so it's like you can there's difference
between genotype and phenotype right
like you can have the genotype
that says you'll have blue eyes but it
doesn't penetrate into your system so
you still have brown eyes uh-huh
recessive gene well yes there's
recessive right
and dominant but allele
there you go 11th grade biology
yeah but there's no genetic test that'll
tell you that
well so people are getting hung up
paying lots of money for things he's
like 23 and me what you're predisposed
to
be sick with we're very dynamic
anything's possible because then it's
also like
if you're living in that anxiety you're
telling me i'm predisposed to something
i'm just going to manifest
getting it 100 i had a patient this was
years and years ago we're giving her
just progesterone
and every time she came in oh is this
going to cause breast cancer
no this is all you're doing is thinking
about breast cancer yeah so a couple
years later husband came into the office
said she was just diagnosed with breast
cancer god
yeah so what what you focus on is what
you get
you go where you look yeah but every
time
and so i think people mess up everybody
that i know that's obsessed with getting
sick they're always sick 100
because if you focus on the bad you'll
get bad if you focus on what you don't
want like the easiest is weight loss
people say oh i'm excited to lose weight
well you're still focused on the weight
so i say focus on oh i want to wear that
bathing suit
that's a different equation focus on
what you want
because you always get it yeah brain
explodes
yeah hard for people to do though it's
amazing really hard
really hard that you know primitive
brain is like feeling the reptile brain
wants you to just
go to the shortcuts and i think we're
addicted to fear i mean
the adrenaline and the fear it's very
addictive it's very easy to live that
way
for sure it's very comfortable to live
that way yeah it is comfortable
you have to get out of that but it's
working it feels like jumping off a
cliff but you just have to like know
there's a net
always 100 i
end these very awkwardly as you know
okay all right now i'm gonna go make you
look at my refrigerator
my needle collection and tell me if
everything's right okay
is there anywhere people should go
follow you website our website is
conibrewellness koniverwellness.com
same thing for instagram connor wellness
yeah that's about it
the best thank you for having me circle
this is so awesome
you're the best well thank you
don't ride elephants guys love you
everything's gonna be fine
[Music]
sorry
[Applause]
wow